[Music]
you're the realms greatest mathematician
but ever since you criticized the
Emperor's tax laws you've been locked in
the dungeon with only a marker to count
the days but one day you're suddenly
brought before the Emperor who looks
even angrier than usual one of his 12
governors has been convicted of paying
his taxes with a counterfeit coin which
has already made its way into the
Treasury as the kingdom's greatest
mathematician you've been granted a
chance to earn your freedom by
identifying the fake before you are the
12 identical looking coins and a balance
scale you know that the false coin will
be very slightly lighter or heavier than
the rest but the Emperor's not a patient
man you may only use the scale three
times before you'll be thrown back into
the dungeon you look around for anything
else you can use but there's nothing in
the room just the coins the scale and
your trusty marker how do you identify
the counterfeit
obviously you can't weigh each coin
against all of the others so you'll have
to weigh several coins at the same time
by splitting the stack into multiple
piles then narrowing down where the
false coin is start by dividing the 12
coins into three equal piles of four
placing two of these on the scale gives
us two possible outcomes
if the two sides balance all eight coins
on the scale are real and the fake must
be among the remaining four so how do
you keep track of these results that's
where the marker comes in mark the eight
authentic coins with a zero now take
three of them and weigh them against
three unmarked coins if they balance the
remaining unmarked coin must be the fake
if they don't draw a plus on the three
unmarked coins if they're heavier or a
minus if they're lighter now take two of
the newly marked coins and weigh them
against each other if they balance the
third coin is fake otherwise look at
their marks if they are plus coins the
heavier one is the imposter if they are
marked with - it's the lighter one but
what if the first two piles you weigh
don't balance mark the coins on the
heavier side with a plus and those on
the lighter side with a minus you can
also mark the remaining four coins with
zeros since you know the fake one is
already somewhere on the scale now
you'll need to think strategically so
you can remove all remaining ambiguity
in just two more weighings to do this
you'll need to reassemble the piles one
method is to replace three of the plus
coins with three of the minus coins and
replace those with three of the zero
coins from here you have three
possibilities
if the previously heavier side of the
scale is still heavier that means either
the remaining plus coin on that side is
actually the heavier one or the
remaining minus coin on the lighter side
is actually the lighter one choose
either one of them and weigh it against
one of the regular coins to see which is
true if the previously heavier side
became lighter that means one of the
three minus coins you moved is actually
the lighter one way two of them against
each other if they balance the third is
counterfeit if not the lighter one is
similarly if the two sides balanced
after your substitution then one of the
three plus coins you
moved must be the heavier one way two of
them against each other if they balance
the third one is fake if not then it's
the heavier one
the emperor nods approvingly at your
finding and the counterfeiting Lord
takes your place in the dungeon
[Music]
you